we have a huge week coming up next week
on the David Pakman show on Monday we
are going to have for you our
investigation into what data we have
regarding the racial aspect to police
shootings and this has been the subject
of much controversy now we've been
telling you that we have been working on
an investigation in an analysis of all
the data we have and that will be
presented to you on Monday looking
forward to that on tuesday i will be
interviewing Sam sacks from the district
Sentinel I told you earlier last week
that the DEA the Drug Enforcement Agency
made the decision to keep marijuana as a
schedule 1 drug I also told you why that
made absolutely no sense and Sam sacks
is going to join me to talk more about
that on Wednesday I will be talking to
Chris Martenson Chris Martenson has been
interviewed on the program two or three
times but it's been years since we had
Chris on and he has a really I would
call it unique and interesting and
relevant approach to the economy and
economics and we're going to talk to him
about real economic questions that are
surfacing now in the wake of increased
automation of Labor the economic plans
of Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump and
so many other things if you have
questions for Chris absolutely let me
know and then on Friday we're going to
go back to a classic interview when i
interviewed jonathan Metzel and one of
the aspects of any gun related situation
uh crime shooting regulations whatever
that is mentioned is the need for these
mental health databases and Jonathan
explain to us how these are very very
racially tinged and we are going to
review that interview just as a reminder
of what you should be really thinking
about when you hear that term a mental
health gun database if you have any
questions at all for any of the guests
let me know david at david pakman.com if
you have suggestions for people you want
me to interview let me know david at
david pakman.com we have a
where any time any of us get suggestions
for guess we put the name on there we
will try to book the guest more than
half of our guests are suggestions from
the audience two other quick things
number one I mentioned this on the show
i'll mention it again david pakman show
is now taking applications for fall
interns these are typically either
people who were in college or recently
graduated the internships are here in
our Boston studio interns don't run
around getting coffee they actually work
on production and marketing work for the
show get in touch david at david
pakman.com about that and lastly we do
have a great membership special going on
right now we recently launched the new
david pakman show website it's
tremendous uh it's it's by far the
absolute best website that we've put
around us the way Donald Trump likes to
say and we have a coupon code that
coupon code is hey tree at 40 thats h
eight ER i OT 40 which will get you a
lifetime forty percent discount off of
the membership of your choice be it
monthly or yearly and you can sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership